what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch the mandalorian
season two episode four today now before
we go into this reaction i did want to
give you guys a heads up that tomorrow
i'm gonna be putting up
a very special video it's a huge
announcement trust me you're gonna want
to tune in especially been a fan of this
channel for a while so make sure to
subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when that video is up
can't wait for you guys to see it it's
something that's near and dear to my
heart
it's big if you end up enjoying this
reaction make sure to hit that like
button
full length reaction watch along where
you sync up with the time code for the
mandalorian is all over at our patreon
page where over there we do
plenty of tv shows we're at the same
tier we have the option for reaction
highlights and
watch along included our good buddy eric
over at nerd chronic has been editing
these for us thank you so much please
give him a follow today
recently edited my clone wars series
finale reaction at the last minute he's
a wonderful editor and just a great dude
overall so
he's earned a follow give him a fall
today anyway let's swing into
action people
including verner herzl very very cool
but very cool we almost missed
no hold them apart no
no
it's a 420 mando video that rgn put out
the marsh hush is a marshall now
how smart what a unique way to deflect
yeah
human shield nice
how's my credit butch
you son of a [ __ ] wherever i go he goes
i know please
he'll be fine yoda's gonna have my word
maybe you're just gonna have some
education he's gonna learn
maybe be able to communicate those
macaroons and look exactly
oh how could you reject the little guy
it's real like ambulant entertainment
vibe about that yeah
how long is this gonna take you're lucky
i even packed it at all
dank ferric what about the cruisers
i'm sure they'll have they'll have other
options in there
it's a mint truck sir marauder you know
how much we can get for this on the
black market
that's what they're gonna escape in
there you go
which shot goes in the thumbnail
i was snapping the trailers they would
always show that image but you never you
never saw a
mithral there yeah destroy it
no oh snap oh
you're hiding something what uh
this is a lab oh we need to get into the
system and figure out what's going on
that's what they they wanted to take
baby yoda oh i think it's all i guess
oh
snap dude it hit so much action in this
episode
superhero landing yeah
it's like classic star wars and that's
sound quality too
over here for a sweet chase
oh here we go here we go yeah yeah
oh jeez speeder bike chase baby
oh wow wow great that one oh my god
halfway down dude
i got one
blasted
oh no do they know that baby oda is back
on navarro
dude if you could take out four tie
fighters you'll be a legend
from the ground [ __ ]
god sounds classic sounds no
boom oh
no
holy moly
yeah
yeah
baby
i still got the macaroons macaroons
enjoying the show i love those locked
off mounted shots
yeah of all the modern scifi
yeah wow man the action in this episode
is so
good oh my god they're playing chicken
oh the razor crest is back not too bad
huh kid
he's gonna throw up that yeah
damn it you will be well rewarded in the
new era
is that that's the repair guy
the tracking beacon has been installed
on the razor crest oh [ __ ]
wow way to go car weather that was great
done carl weathers
that was a wonderful episode there's so
much information just enough to keep it
very mysterious yeah exactly because the
persian guy said
he drew blood from the child
and he said m count which i'm assuming
our midichlorian count
and if that if and then he tried they
said like the body rejected it
yeah whatever they were testing it on
didn't take it was it those people in
the tank
was it that's what i would assume or at
least what's up
yeah are they making palpatine's right
now or are they making snokes
yeah i mean in the way how clone wars
made
for me made that i think where a lot of
people made uh the prequels
better maybe maybe there's something
maybe this is something that's better
maybe the entire achievement of the
mandalorian series
is to just make the sequels better
i mean it certainly seems like they've
added in some things that directly
benefited this year
yeah we'll have to go back to that after
i was really impressed with the way he
handled his direction yeah
every director this season is really
like knocking out the park yeah
yeah bob brought their own flair all
right let's talk about it okay
so there's actually kind of a lot here
to sort of unpack
i mean i want to talk about the
filmmaking and i also
obviously want to talk about some things
that could lead to some huge reveals
my take on this especially that scene
with dr pershing
you see those scientists there who are
wearing outfits that are similar to what
he wore
as well in the first season my take on
this is that this is
starting to tie more into the sequels
now whereas this show before
was normally tie-ins to like you know
like as we saw last episode clone wars
or to the
classic films prior installments what
have you my
interpretation of what they're talking
about seems like they're tying it kind
of closer into
some revelations that we got in rise of
skywalker specifically which i find
interesting because i
was under the impression they're kind of
just ignoring that other than teasing
and setting up some building to getting
the first order included in here he
mentions emcount which has to be the
midichlorians from
my recollection the snokes were clones
the
emperor is a clone in riza skywalker but
in order to make a clone body force
sensitive they have to have a
midichlorian count as well
it seems like baby yoda or whatever his
real name is
force sensitive child has a midichlorian
count in him a really high one so maybe
this is like
the creation of snoke that we're first
going to start seeing i let my mind
flash directly too
that's what it looked like at first i
was like they're trying to edge they're
experimenting on bodies suspended in
liquid and they're trying to tap
yeah the force sensitivity being
compatible with that it certainly sounds
like yeah the early stages of endless
supplies of dark lords
we're gonna start getting some real tie
into the rise of the first order
even setting up a little bit with cara
dune there i mean when she's asked about
it you lose no one although ron i'm like
i thought
it wasn't alderaan obliterated it was
destroyed i
feel like anyone from alderaan probably
was someone at the time
yeah it seemed like they were teasing
that she might even join the new
republic the biggest takeaway i got
okay that that seems to be the main use
of why they've been trying to hunt down
baby yoda specifically
is so they can take out the middle
clarence room but does that mean baby
was gonna die
it seems like it's inevitable that he's
gonna die because clearly in the
sequel films they succeed they succeed
with the cloning process
he has to die eventually either that or
we find eventually where he came from
and that there are maybe a few
more or something take this one well
you know but in in finding and
discovering a lost
place you can also lead people to it you
know so i i wouldn't necessarily
jump directly although at the same time
with the
rarity of that species within the series
i certainly wouldn't
just put that dread aside especially
with how tenacious they are about
catching him
off gideon as the dark saber now yes
very much still out there i mean we saw
the end of the episode he's got like a
whole
setup of new troopers ready to go and
those troopers i thought they were death
troopers but
for some reason they read to me as some
type of android trooper
if you guys know please let if you guys
have a clue as to who they might be
please let me know in the comments
because i don't know what it is yeah it
felt
like oh we just built these you know
soldiers that will
yeah it felt like one of those things
where we're building an unstoppable army
of either clones or robots or something
it felt more droid-like the way they
were working on them and how they were
hooked up they didn't seem like they
were
sentient beings necessarily they felt
different so yeah there's a lot of
star wars-y things to grab from here of
how they're linking towards
disney sequels and i i'd be cool with
that i feel like some fans
probably would hate that because i think
they just want those to be ignored
but they don't think they're going to be
ignored and you know mandalorian isn't
exists
as much as mandalorian is more of a pure
star wars
story than maybe the disney sequels are
those are still mandalorian is still a
disney produced property i think they're
going to want to tie it
you know there's a it doesn't matter and
i feel like in the end it could perhaps
even make those sequels better which is
what i'm hoping for
kind of like what i said with clone wars
about clone wars makes the prequels
better well that's one of the nice
things about the
media ecosystem of star wars and that's
what i guess i hope
for with this if they're going to do
things that hearken to the sequels
because if
you know you think back to season one
they bring up baby yoda's ability to
heal with the force
around the same time that the rise of
skywalker yeah so is to kind of
not that they did that to explain but at
the same time
in the public eye it feels that way yeah
and so
you know i hope that these corners of
the world that relate directly to the
pre uh sequels
naturally part of fleshing out the
overall world and less sort of uh damage
control retroactively yeah you know
because also
it doesn't serve you to do that that
just keeps the wound open you know
and there were some design aesthetics
because this show
normally feels like classic star wars
but there are some things with the
production design that at times felt
like it was starting to
merge a little bit more with what the
first order might appear as
so i really do feel like this is what
we're getting the early stages the
conception of that
this is how the first order rises after
we've already had an experience like the
empire putting that aside i do want to
talk about the filmmaking because
carl weathers i'm not let me do a quick
imdb search
i want to know if he's directed anything
else okay so he's directed a bunch of
other tv
shows but mandalorians is an exception
because from my understanding with the
mandalorian the directors get a lot more
creative freedom than
most television shows it's like yes you
got to work within the confines
of making sure the storytelling's on par
and you know proper connectivity and
stuff you can't just ryan johnson
but in terms of how you want to direct
your episode or capture it i hear that
the directors get a lot more creative
freedom and how they want to go about it
and i was
very impressed with how we did this one
it goes without saying the visual
effects are once again
top-notch i thought he captured the mood
perfectly and the suspenseful buildup
and there were times
where there's a little bit i don't know
if the right word's tongue-in-cheek but
there's
some elements that feel like they harken
back to a little bit more of a classic
action movie from the 80s or 90s certain
mood tone pieces especially like
cara dunes first scene that's another
one of the stars gonna go back to star
wars talking the armor wasn't there and
the mythosaur skull wasn't there either
so where did the armorer go off to yeah
which i'm sure we'll
we'll have to get around to because it
would see them again it was being raided
and it didn't look like the people
those creatures uh whose name i don't
know but those creatures
it didn't look like they had the methyl
skull i am assuming considering
how important and significant the
mythosaurus skull is it seemed like they
were scavenging rather than they took it
by force or something
yeah yeah i mean an armorer could easily
fend them off that action scene
and then certain other earmarks of the
dynamics of the dialogue it's kind of
felt like classical action to me and
like an 80s or 90s movie but i thought
his build was so well done
like you could always feel that there's
something ramping up and it kept
getting bigger bigger bigger it starts
off with you're fighting some
stormtroopers there
mando escapes jets off and they break
out with the ship and then speeder bikes
then tie fires
then uh razorcrest battle tough battling
tie fighters and i thought the
the way he captured aerial shots the way
he captured on the ground
uh speeder by chase sequence was awesome
like he really
brought a fresh spin here on action
sequences for the mandalorian and to me
this is some of the best action the
mandalorian has ever produced
and i feel like carl weather's knocked
it out of the park here
for all the freedom you also get the
extra bump in
resources i feel like coming out of most
regular tv to
something like the mandalorian what
you're really doing is making
a 40-minute feature film basically and
so yeah to see carl weathers be able to
bring
some of that sensibility that you know i
mean from films like predator and all
sorts of
action roles like to be able to see him
then take
those years of expertise and sculpt this
episode that yeah has
a lot of those really fun mandalorian
just character moments but then some
really dazzling action with again yeah
when that
i i was really gripped especially by
that one descending
shot of the speeder bikes when the two
guys crash into each other
like there's a lot of happenstance too
in this episode that felt very natural
and very much like that western again
just keeping the consistency up
with the tone and that's the thing is
that's what's impressive i think
especially about having so many
different directors many of them coming
from an acting background or other
backgrounds than just this kind of
filmmaking
yeah who are able to you know put their
stamp on these pieces but also keep this
flow
you really get that feel of a small
group pulling off a really hard mission
and then what goes wrong during that
mission and walking into a situation
that's way bigger than they initially
thought it was especially like i love
the the centerpiece when they get into
the room with the experiments in it and
they're all
realizing how much deeper this goes you
know the whole like this isn't a
military vessel this is a laugh yeah
this isn't just some place i gotta blow
up there are people operating out of
here yeah
i thought horatio sans mithral bringing
him back here was
great i thought he was funnier and like
more
more
enjoyable than he was in the first
season and speaking of which this is a
return to navarro so in a lot of ways
it's a return to the first episode you
bring back mithral
you're seeing how navarro has changed so
much whereas the first time you check in
with navarro
feels very desolate scum you know it
feels like downtrodden
poverty-stricken forgotten by the yeah
ruled by
gangs you know it has that kind of slum
vibe where
here you first check in it's like bright
it's beautiful it's colorful
bustling they've shuttered exactly
they've shifted that bar
into a school for for children i got to
go back and see what that protocol droid
was talking about because i'm like i bet
there's something there that i missed oh
yeah
yeah i want to go back and listen to
that but seeing how much navarro has
changed but then
again with his direction it's bright and
beautiful and then they're talking about
how
there's parts of the imperial army that
are still here on navarro the last
shred and then you start traveling and
it just gets more gloomy
and gray and disgusting and desolate and
abandoned chasing back
it's trying to get back to the the good
side of it
yeah and then they win it's like when
they win when when
razer kraut mando takes out the the last
high fighters it's back in a beautiful
sunshiny kind of light yeah you know
like the the light side wins this battle
today
yeah you know visual storytelling carl
weather
i thought he i thought he did a great
job here um there's a lot to unpack here
and yeah you actually get a better sense
of
what the mandalorian show is really all
about uh in terms of tying it into the
bigger part of the star wars universe as
well which
is what we've all been sort of expecting
season two
to to go about and do i'm happy with it
i love i love this one i thought this
was a really
solid really rocking soccer episode with
some exceptional action for the series
yeah and macaroons are now canon
macaroons blue macaroons bluemax blue
milk blue max
yeah duncan's perfect blue snacks right
there
all right guys well what's your
interpretation off of what we saw in
that experimental room leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell keep a look out for
that video on sunday that i'm gonna put
up which should be tomorrow last but not
least let's do a
daniel gallagher i just wanted to tell
you today you've been part of our
patreon page
pretty much since the beginning with it
being thanksgiving season you're someone
who i'm extremely grateful
to have in our lives i don't know too
many people who are as loyal
as you to us so i appreciate the sense
of loyalty you might not even be able to
have the time to check out our videos
because of how busy your life can be or
even our patreon videos or even
messaging back from time to time because
of how time-consuming everything is you
have going on in your life yet
you've never left our patreon page
you've always shown your support you've
always stayed pledged
that level of support really does not go
unnoticed so thank you so much for being
you dude
uh it's been like a couple years you've
been with us now and i'll forever be
grateful for the man
the scottish pharmacist daniel gallagher
thank you dude thanks buddy